In the last video, I talked
about the two campaigns that
eventually lead to Napoleon's
downfall.
One of those was the Peninsular
Campaign.
Where Napoleon and the French
Empire had to waste a
significant amount of resources
fighting and trying
to hold Spain.
And the other, almost more
direct catalyst for the fall
of Napoleon, was his
invasion of Russia.
We're going to see in this is
video why it was so disastrous
for Napoleon.
This is easily one of the top
five, I would say, famous
military campaigns in
all of history.
So let's remind ourselves the
relationship between Napoleon,
or between the French
Empire and Russia.
After the Fourth Coalition, you
might remember the Treaty
of Tilsit, they're friends.
Russia was part of the
Continental System, which
means that they would boycott
or that they would not trade
with Britain.
Or allow Britain to use
any of Russia's ports.
And Russia was allowed to do
anything that they want with
the Ottoman Empire.
So everything was good.
But then we move forward
to 1811.
We're in 1811 and Russia
starts relaxing the
Continental System.
Essentially meaning that they
started to trade a little bit
with Britain.
So this all of a sudden begins
to annoy, it angers Napoleon.
In order for an embargo to
work, in order for the
Continental System to work,
everyone on the continent has
to not trade with Britain.
Because if someone trades with
Britain, Britain could just
trade with them and then that
trade could circulate through
the rest of Europe.
So in order for this to work,
it has to be total.
So this already annoys
Napoleon.
Especially because he defeated
the Russians
in the Fourth Coalition.
In the Treaty of Tilsit
he thought he was
being nice to them.
Just don't do any trade with
Great Britain, we're going to
be good buddies.
But then what really got
Napoleon is in 1812, he hears
that Russia is thinking about
taking the French Empire's
part of Poland, or the
Duchy of Warsaw.
So Russia thinking about
taking Poland.
So Napoleon figures, gee, we're
no longer friends, I
better attack them
preemptively.
So against the advice of a lot
of people about actually
invading Russia, Napoleon
decides to invade.
So this directly leads
to Napoleon invading.
And his other option, obviously,
would have been
just to defend Poland
from Russia.
But Napoleon, he just says no,
look if they're going to
double cross me like that, I'm
just going to go full tilt and
show them who's boss.
So he decides to invade
in April of 1812.
And Napoleon is no dummy.
He realizes that the Russian
winter is really vicious.
So he says, if I start in the
late spring like this and I
engage the Russians and I
decisively defeat them,
everything will be
said and done.
And I'll be Emperor of
Russia, as well.
Before Russia even begins
to get cold.
So what I'm going to do here,
to just understand how
devastating this campaign ends
up being to Napoleon, I'm
going to use one of the
most famous charts in
the history of charts.
Some people consider this
to be the best, most
well-designed chart ever.
And this was created
by Charles-- let
me use another color.
I keep using this.
This was created by Charles
Joseph Minard.
You can actually get a bigger
version of this on Wikipedia.
But that was too big
for my screen.
So this is a smaller version.
But it's a fascinating chart.
So what it shows is the size
of Napoleon's army as it
invades Russia.
And the size of the army is
shown by the width of this
brown line right here.
So when he starts invading
Russia, he has 450,000 men.
If you could read this number,
that's what it says.
And you can find zoomed
versions on the web.
If you just do a search on this
and on the invasion of
Russia, you'll find
this chart.
It's very, very famous.
More than even teaching you the
history, this is also just
a neat chart to look at.
And it's something that
you should be
exposed to at some point.
But as you can see, and just
so you have some scope of
what's going on, not only does
it show you the size of his
forces, it shows the path
that it travels.
And you can already see that as
the forces are travelling,
the number of the soldiers in
the force is getting smaller
and smaller.
And he keeps updating
the numbers.
So obviously that width is
smaller than that width, by it
looks like it's less than half
the forces at this point than
at this point.
And just to understand where
this is going on, here is a
map of Eastern Europe.
And Charles Joseph Minard's map
starts right around here
in Lithuania.
So this is where the Napoleon
forces were strongest, where
he had 450,000.
And it kind of goes like this.
This is Moscow right here.
So this is kind of
the endpoint.
And if I were to trace this
shape onto here, it would look
something like this.
I'm just trying to
show the path.
Roughly like this.
And then you get to Moscow.
So that line is the same
thing as that line.
Just so you have some context
within the broader
geography of Europe.
So it's starting off, in what's
almost exactly the
northeastern border of
present-day Poland, or you
could say the southwestern
border
of what's now Lithuania.
Crosses through what
is now Belarus.
And then goes on into Russia.
Now, as you can see here, I
already pointed out, that as
he's traveling, as the forces
are travelling, these 450,000
men, horses, and armaments, and
cannons, and everything
else is getting thinner
and thinner.
And one is, it's just basic
military logistics.
You have to keep your
supply routes open.
You have to keep leaving men
behind to essentially guard
the supply routes.
So just as the longer your
campaign, and the further into
enemy territory you have, you
have to keep leaving men
behind to guard it.
And this whole time, Napoleon
kept wanting to engage with
the Russians.
The whole time that he was
travelling, he kept expecting
to engage the Russians.
But just as he was about to
engage the Russians, the
Russians would back
up a little bit.
And this kept happening.
They're were small skirmishes,
so obviously he lost some
troops here or there.
But most of this was just to
maintain the supply line.
Eventually, he is able to have,
I guess we could say, a
skirmish, I don't want to say
a skirmish, it was actually
maybe a brief battle
with the Russians
in August in Smolensk.
And that is, let me make sure
I get it right on the map,
right there.
But once again, Napoleon
was victorious.
But the Russians retreated, it
wasn't a decisive victory over
the Russian army.
Eventually, he just keeps
chasing them, keeps chasing
them, until we get to
September 7, 1812.
And now you could imagine that
we're kind of in the fall now.
And it gets cold quickly
out here in Russia.
So already, it's getting to be a
kind of precarious position.
But Napoleon is confident.
He's like, you know what?
If I can decisively defeat the
Russians, I can take Moscow.
Moscow will have food it in.
And all will be said and done.
And that's actually brings
up another point.
You might remember when I talked
about the War of the
Third Coalition, that Napoleon,
and in general good
military tactics to invade
during the fall.
Because of fall is the
harvest season.
That way you don't have to
have as many supplies
carried with you.
You don't have to guard the
supply routes as carefully.
Because you can just go and take
all of the farmer's crops
to feed your troops.
But what the Russians did is
what they call scorched earth
tactics, which essentially
means exactly
what it sounds like.
As the Russians kept retreating
back, they burned
everything that could be of
benefit to Napoleon's troops.
So they burned all the fields
as they retreated, so that
Napoleon's troops couldn't
access the local resources.
So they had to keep having a
very-- I guess you could say--
costly supply chain from where
they started, as opposed to
just feeding off of the land.
And the Russians just
continued to do this
on and on and on.
All the way to Moscow.
All the way to September 1812,
where we have the Battle of
Borodino, if I'm saying
it correctly.
And at this point, Napoleon
only had a 135,000 of his
original 450,000 men.
The rest had to be left behind
to guard the supply route.
Or they deserted because they
were starting to get hungry.
Or they were lost just with
minor skirmishes that happened
along the entire way.
And at the Battle of Borodino,
after a long, protracted,
super bloody battle, in which--
let me write these
numbers down-- 44-- and these
are all estimates-- 44,000
Russian casualties.
Mostly death, but also
wounded or captured.
And 35,000 French.
Many historians think this is
the most of bloody day of
battle up to this
day in history.
The French are victorious.
So we have a French
victory here.
So Napoleon is feeling
good about himself.
Borodino is right outside
of Moscow.
He's like, you know what?
I'm just going to walk
into Moscow.
They're going to hand the keys
of the city over to me.
And then my troops are going to
have a good time in Moscow
being able to eat all the
food that must be there.
And I will now be Emperor
of Russia, as well.
So about a week later, he walks
into Moscow and it's
completely deserted.
All of the inhabitants have left
and they've taken all the
food with them.
And then on top of that,
Moscow starts burning.
And there's some debate as
to why Moscow burned.
Some historians believe it
is because the Russians
deliberately set fire
to the city.
Some believe that it was just
a tinder box waiting to burn
and Napoleon's troops were just
a little irresponsible
with where they built fires.
It's not clear.
But needless to say, it made
Moscow useless to Napoleon.
And this is kind of
a major change.
Napoleon just expected look,
if I beat your army
decisively, like I did it
at Borodino, I won.
I take the city.
Now, you should give me
food and shelter.
And I'm your new Emperor.
But the Russians had something
different in mind.
They said, no you will
never take Russia.
You can have Moscow.
You can have a burned Moscow.
There's nothing in it.
And we'll just like to see you
retreat in the Moscow winter.
And by Napoleon's own accounts,
this is a quote that
he gave. The most terrible of
all my battles was the one
before Moscow.
The French showed themselves
to be worthy of victory.
This is at Borodino.
But the Russians show themselves
worthy of being
invincible.
So with no one to recognize
Napoleon or to help him out or
to feed his troops, he's kind
of in a worthless Moscow.
He decides to just turn around,
especially because the
Russian winter is approaching.
So on this chart you can see
they went all the way to
Moscow, they had
135,000 troops.
They lose 35,000 of them.
So you have 100,000 troops
coming back.
This black line, right here,
this represents the retreat.
And then things start
getting cold.
So it's really interesting
about this
chart that Minard made.
It has a couple things.
You see the route that
Napoleon's army took as it
went into Russia.
Then in black, this
is its retreat.
It gets thinner and thinner
and thinner.
And you see where they went.
And on top of that,
he shows the
temperature as they retreated.
And this is on something called
a Reaumur scale, but
you can just multiply these
numbers, if you can
see them, by 1.25.
So you can see that it was
already, it was not that bad.
But over here, we're already
below freezing.
We're well below freezing
over here.
At the coldest point, if
Minard's numbers are right,
and I've seen some historians
contest the numbers, but it
was cold nonetheless.
It's negative 37 degrees as
we start approaching into
November and December.
So Napoleon's forces, as before,
they had this whole
supply chain.
They had scorched earth.
So there's nothing to eat.
They still had nothing to eat.
Then it started getting cold.
And while it was cold and they
were retreating, some of the
troops would desert.
They would be attacked
by peasants.
Just little bit by little bit
they'd be attacked by various
Russian forces.
And then kind of the final blow
was when they were trying
to cross the Berezina River.
So this right here is
the Berezina River.
And you can even see from
Minard's chart that the width
was respectable.
But then after trying
to cross that
river, it just got decimated.
Almost half of the soldiers
died or disappeared.
And these are depictions, these
are paintings, of the
retreat of Napoleon's forces
in the winter.
This is actually a painting of
the crossing of Berezina.
And by the time that the forces
got back at the end of
1812-- all the way over here,
by Minard's map-- you only
have 10,000 troops of the
original 450,000.
So only 1 in 45 returned.
The other were either captured,
deserted, or just died.
So when this happened, you could
imagine, not only did
Napoleon lose so many soldiers,
also lost on the
order of 200,000 horses.
Actually, total casualties for
this one campaign, the
estimates are about 300,000
French troops.
The estimates I saw had about
200,000 Russian troops.
And just to be clear, a big
portion of the French troops
died as they tried to retreat.
And then there was a huge amount
of Russian civilian
casualties.
And there were also soldiers
from other countries
participating, especially
on the French side.
When all is said and done,
estimates are over 1 million
dead from the French invasion.
But beyond even just the human
casualties, Napoleon lost on
the order of 200,000 horses.
I forgot the exact number,
but thousands of canons.
So you could imagine, that it
was just this huge, huge loss
to the French military.
So by the time this was done,
the rest of the powers of
Europe could kind of finally see
Napoleon being weakened.
He was already bogged down
in the peninsula.
He had this huge defeat as he
tried to invade Russia.
They finally realized that now
is the time that they can form
maybe a Sixth Coalition and
really take Napoleon out.